and we are honored to be joined by
someone who's been thinking about this
for an awful long time that would be
glenn greenwald who writes for sub stack
he has been covering the national
security state for decades saying things
that in retrospect have proved to be
totally true we're happy to have him
joining us now glenn thanks so much for
coming on so as a as just noted you have
been on the trail of the national
security state long before most people
thought it was anything more than a
conspiracy theory as we now say
who do you think is actually in charge
of the government at this point
it's bizarre tucker because the trump uh
presidency brought so much evidence
showing us
who was one of the video clips i always
point to is when chuck schumer went on
to rachel maddow's show
days before trump was inaugurated when
he had posted something criticizing the
cia for getting a rock wrong and chuck
schumer said
ethics aside how can donald trump be so
stupid as to do that to the cia if you
challenge the cia they have six
different ways to sunday to get back at
you and the entire trump presidency was
driven by
all sorts of narratives from the media
about how these heroic independent
generals like mattis and john kelly and
h.r mcmaster were going to save us from
the elected president and there were all
kinds of reports about how these
security state officials would conceal
classified information that they didn't
want president trump to have in order to
manipulate his decision-making or even
subvert or ignore his decision-making
like when he would tell them to withdraw
troops from syria and they would lie to
him and pretend they did when they just
moved them instead and this was
celebrated while at the same time they
would say if you say that there's a deep
state in the united states which is
nothing more than what dwight eisenhower
warned about a permanent power faction
in washington that rules the country
regardless of the outcome of election
they would tell you that you were crazy
like you were a conspiracy theory even
as they were cheering for the classic
definition of the deep state in the
first place so you have to be a
conspiracy theorist or incredibly
gullible not to believe that that exists
so here's the evidence that that won me
over it you know it famously people say
if you wonder who's really in charge who
you're not allowed to criticize what's
the one group
republicans and democrats never
criticize the national security state i
mean republicans are happy to go after
the irs or the education department i
can't remember the last time a
republican leader meaningfully
criticized doj or the pentagon and of
course democrats are exactly the same
that kind of tells you everything
doesn't it
exactly and the the amazing thing is i
mean for whatever flaws you want to
point to in donald trump's compartment
and governance right which i think there
are several valid ones one of the most
important things that he did was he
deviated from that cage that presidents
have been kept in which is he told the
american people there are these security
state agents who think that they run the
government and he stood up to them and
challenged their orthodoxies and pieties
and showed americans especially people
in the republican party on the right
that these institutions are not noble or
benevolent but are highly pernicious
they want to interfere in our domestic
politics and they ought to be deeply
distrusted i think that was one of the
most important things he did and it was
for that reason his willingness to
criticize them that they hated him and
spent four years trying to undermine his
presidency and tucker the amazing thing
is they always talk about the sanctity
of democracy how is democracy more
threatened than having unelected people
who operate in the dark free to
undermine and sabotage the person that
americans chose as the president well
except thank you exactly i mean if you
want to wreck democracy that's how you
do it i think there's a lot of evidence
the last president was really concerned
about their power on a personal level
like he understood how powerful they
were really quick
do you think at this stage it would be
possible for a president
to push back and to strip the unelected
power centers of some of their power in
our government
you would need a big army behind you i
mean that's why people in washington
were petrified of j edgar hoover he kept
dossiers through the fbi on every
politician in washington they do have a
lot of amass power you need the
population to rise up against them for
that to work
yeah boy i hope that happens just
because you know i think democracy is
worth having i know you feel that way
too glenn greenwald an
anti-authoritarian we're proud to have
thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else